if you're gonna be a startup founder you
have to be crazy you started advised
when you were 16 you're how old now i'm
22. we did college courses at
northwestern twelve yeah twelve i think
like some of the greatest philosophers
of our time are also crazy people and i
think connie is a crazy person and crazy
people have different views on the world
that you know can sometimes be reflected
how do you know if he's crazy or if he's
right and then you and i live in a
bubble where it seems like crypto is the
most important thing there's 85 trillion
dollars in assets sitting with financial
advisors and it's growing at this
staggering rate founders get too
obsessed especially young founders with
status right i fell into this trap if
you can't nail customers in product
you're gonna fail at everything else all
right guys bang bang i've got samia here
with me uh i'm very excited to talk to
you you started a company when you were
very young you've scaled it at an
incredible pace but i thought a great
place to start would actually be with a
tweet that i dug up uh from the past
which was kanye west is the most
brilliant philosopher of our lifetime uh
i tend to agree but i'd love to hear
your thought process as to why kanye is
so
philosophically superior to others maybe
that are living right now
yeah i mean i've been tweeting a lot
lately so maybe that one stands out for
sure you know i think i was listening to
a kanye song i was just super inspired i
think there was this quote of his of
like
you know not having money is everything
but having money isn't everything and i
was like
pretty insightful yeah well that's part
of uh i think most good songs is like uh
my brothers and i always joke like bars
right if a good tweet is essentially
just like a one-liner whether that's a
stand-up joke whether that is
some kind of lyric from a music song
like ultimately the ability to
communicate complex ideas very simply uh
and in short form is a pretty powerful
concept today yeah i think he's
incredible doing that and i think like
some of the greatest philosophers of our
time are also crazy people and i think
kanye is a crazy person and crazy people
have different views on the world that
you know can sometimes be reflected how
do you know if he's crazy or if he's
right
you know i don't know but i think i've
heard some stories from some friends
that know him that seem absolutely crazy
that you know even the most
right person would would not do so
i don't know
well it begs the question like if you
start especially thinking of like
startup founders like can you be crazy
and right right like to some degree uh
i always think about like it's crazy
until it works right so when people sit
down and they're like i'm going to do x
everyone's like hey okay crazy person
and then all of a sudden you accomplish
it then it's like oh you were right
but at the same time um what's his line
i think like uh show me a genius that's
not crazy yeah and so it begs the
question of like how do you label when
somebody's doing something different uh
ultimately just are they right or not
look if you're gonna be a startup
founder you have to be crazy and i think
the startup founders that fail right and
sometimes fail in really meaningful ways
like if you look at like elizabeth
holmes and yes like she committed fraud
but like if somehow theranose worked
everyone would make her look out like a
genius right even if there's the fraud
behind it right or adam newman or any of
these other people um you know they're
all crazy every founder is crazy it's
just the ones that are successful are
the ones that write the history books
not the ones that fail yeah and when you
think about that where do you see that
showing up the most like when you say
crazy is it the speed at which they want
to build the company is it their vision
of uh doing something so disruptive to a
market like how do you measure whether a
founder if you were to sit down and talk
to them is crazy or you know maybe they
don't have that it uh component to be a
founder
so
i think it always starts with the vision
right if you are a founder and you
believe you can disrupt an industry that
like has probably done the same thing
the same way for the last i don't know
how many decades you are objectively
crazy to think that you can take that on
because all of the odds the whole deck
is stacked against you so you have to be
crazy in that sense i think the other
side that it shows right you can look at
any of these founders like steve jobs or
others that like they are just crazy in
how they operate right they have
extremely high bar like for talent for
expectations from others and they expect
everyone to operate at a certain level
that you know people just generally
don't tend to operate if you're not a
non-founder so they have those
expectations for the people they work
with like they can be difficult people
yeah
how much does age play into it right
like you're a young person who i think
you started advised when you were 16
you're how old now i'm 22 22 now so for
six years right you've been running this
business uh 22 is still very young
compared to most people in the workforce
uh and kind of the critical traditional
market um
do people lose the craziness as they get
older or do the special people just keep
it at no no matter the age so what
happens is you get a little bit more
jaded as you get older so when you're
young you have this like certain naivety
about you that like you believe because
you don't know how hard something is
going to be that you can take it on it's
like when we first started so my
co-founder and i met at the age of 12 at
summer camp
and with summer camp we were our parents
are like oh you cannot do normal summer
camp you need to do college courses so
we did we did college courses at uh at
northwestern okay and his dorm was
across her mind and the two of twelve
yeah twelve okay and the two of us you
know we started an app development firms
we started building apps for small
medium-sized businesses but you know
when we came out of that like our idea
was like how can we use ai to build apps
like what if you could just what if
anyone could just type in an app idea
and our system will build you an app
using artificial intelligence that is a
really really really hard problem
and you know we didn't know that we
couldn't solve it at the time and we
couldn't end up solving it but when
you're really young you believe you can
do things that you didn't know were
possible and sometimes you can make the
impossible happen and just because you
didn't know that that could happen is
why it happens
and when you think of kind of this idea
of i just want to dictate to a machine
to create something uh if we were
talking 10 years ago like that sounds
insane right now we're starting to see
with gbt3 uh maybe with dali like a
couple of these services
you can't maybe go create the full
application that's super complex that
would serve all the needs of a user uh
i've seen some people do like super
simple things like you know it'll auto
click something uh or whatever uh but
also we're getting uh hey write me an
essay or hey create this piece of art
out of just a couple of words that i
dictate to the machine and so does it
feel like the path that we're on
eventually we will be able to solve that
problem where somebody could just
describe an application and build it
yeah i mean i think the limiting regen
has always been like it's a data problem
okay right and i think the challenge was
like chips weren't designed previously
to be able to you know process nearly as
much data like the training data sets
you need to build let's say an app or
write an essay or something like that
just previously we're not possible right
and for now like especially as you look
at the evolution with moore's law right
the
data we're able to process right the
data gpt3 for example is able to process
is truly incredible and the the
things that that thing will be able to
create over the next five to ten years
are going to be pretty pretty endless
talk uh for those that don't know how
this works right like so you get a data
set where are they getting the data sets
from and then how are they actually
training uh these models on those data
sets so that when i go and i use it i
just type in you know hey write me a
paper on something it just kicks it out
and i think it's magic but like what is
the work that went into actually
creating the quote-unquote artificial
intelligence uh that i'm using so for
like a like a grammarly or something
like that um
you are collecting lots and lots of data
from
like you know pre-existing
like content right like either like
broken down sentences or like what it
looks like to be correct the challenge
is like data labeling right so my buddy
at scale ai created this really great
company to kind of help solve this
problem but it's like how do you train
the model on what's actually right and
what it should pattern match like if you
think about any of these ai models
they're just functionally pattern
matching so like how do you pattern
match to what is right versus what is
wrong that the algorithm can pattern
match too so you need to the challenge
in this problem is how do you
effectively label these data sets and
the way people label the data sets is
they have you know teams of people
in like india or you know really
low-cost places where they're manually
labeling these data sets and those data
sets labeled are going to be fed to
these algorithms
and when that problem is solved in some
kind of automated way which i think
we're still kind of far from but scale
has definitely made a lot of progress
towards doing that um you know you're
going to see a lot more progress on you
know broad ai so a couple of things that
jumped to mind uh mechanical turk right
obviously amazon has this service where
you basically can put in some data it
will get labeled essentially for you uh
and then you can get it back and you can
do quality control or whatever but for
the most part uh that is one thing that
you could do another is a lot of the
captchas now uh will show you you know
six or seven photos and it's like hey
click for uh click the three that have
uh the sidewalk right or the the chimney
or uh school bus or a bicycle or
whatever uh and then someone you're
getting people on the internet to
actually train the data for you right
exactly or like in you know in the
instance of tesla i think like what's
brilliant about their self-driving car
is like they you know you've got all
these self-driving car companies that
have to send cars out on the road and
like you know have engineers go out and
sit with them and you know drive them
and collect data whereas tesla has the
data of every tesla out there that's
going out and collecting self-driving
car data
and is it the idea like tesla as an
example the compounding nature of every
single day they're basically collecting
almost as much data probably as google's
collected you know in its lifetime uh
and i don't know if that's exactly
correct but definitely uh directionally
and so if you do that for a decade tesla
just has such a mountain of data and so
many more insights than any of the other
uh
companies and therefore that advantage
is almost insurmountable exactly right
you can use your scale like that's what
the genius of some of these big
platforms are is they're able to use
their scale leverage that to collect
data and then that data can kind of
improve their products and kind of
unlock things that they couldn't do
before you mentioned scale uh ai what
are they doing so scale ai is like a
data labeling company right so they're
building you know technology basically
augmented by artificial intelligence to
help like label data sets got it and the
data sets are just anything somebody can
feed them or do they use specific types
of data sets i think it started with
self-driving cars now they're like
working with the military it's different
types of data sets so you could feed
them a data set and theoretically they
could label it got it and so when we
think about this labeling of data and
then the ability to extract insights and
then apply it for whatever the use case
is uh one thing i always hear my
nerdiest friends say is like artificial
intelligence doesn't exist it's machine
learning when you hear that like talk
through a little bit of the nuance
between like machine learning and
artificial intelligence artificial
intelligence is an umbrella term right
it always has been like maybe you can
conflate like agi artificial general
intelligence with like the broad term of
ai but like artificial intelligence is a
general term
that can kind of encapsulate lots of
different things machine learning being
one of them and like where we've seen
the most progress and i'm a little rusty
on this because we've kind of strayed
away from the ai focus which i'll talk
about in a little bit um is like machine
learning right so narrow intelligence so
you've got ai applied to one problem set
um one kind of narrow solution that you
are applying kind of some kind of
machine learning algorithm to so once
you have a data set and it's labeled
talk about the machine learning itself
like what is happening there in terms of
the insights or the applications people
are able to use with this machine
learning on a labeled data set
so you have a recurrent neural net like
some kind of neural network and the
neural network has nodes and it's able
to draw conclusions and basically draw a
pattern so given the set of data this is
what we expect to happen not necessarily
a
an algorithm where it's just a set of
instructions basically so it is a black
box in some ways
because we're trying to interpret a
pattern given this broad set of data and
the better data you have the better
pattern recognition you're fundamentally
going to get so in the most basic sense
like you could think of hey i've got a
set of data i've already kind of
massaged it and helped synthesize it to
some degree via the labeling and all the
stuff i throw it to a machine learning
model which has these neural nets in it
and all i'm really saying is like yo
find the patterns basically and then the
machine's like cool here's the patterns
and then i can go do whatever i want
with it yeah and your model is only as
good as the data you feed into it right
and the challenge is oftentimes
explainability right so when you think
about financial models right like in our
instance we sell to wealth managers
right wealth managers want to understand
the why behind their trades right why
was this decision made
and when we started we built a pure ai
model and i think the challenge was
you know we couldn't you know the model
performed very very well right but you
couldn't explain you know here's how
this algorithm jumped to the conclusion
of why we made this set of trades right
we were looking at a set of data we were
trying to find the patterns of that data
and then we you know had an output and
we didn't know how the model basically
came to that output and was the problem
uh in that scenario like people
they're like i don't trust the box like
i don't trust i don't trust the computer
uh i need to understand what the
computer's doing in order to put my
trust in in the conclusion or what was
the kind of limiting factor there so
generally speaking i think people just
trust the box
like in most problems with a finance
problem people when they're giving you
all your money um all their money they
want to understand how did the algorithm
make decisions but it was like split
right some people are like look this is
the future like we're gonna trust this
algorithm and others were saying you
know i want to understand how the
decisions are made so i think the
reality is you have to get somewhere in
the middle yeah i always think of like
google maps right which again is just
looking at streets and trying to figure
out how to move from point a to point b
uh would people follow the directions if
they only showed you the next step like
if there wasn't actually the line on the
road that showed you okay you're here
this is how you're gonna get there uh if
they just said go right and you didn't
know what was coming after that like
there is an element of humans to be like
ah should i go right or what you know
where are you taking me by being able to
see the full route uh before you kind of
hit you know start yeah i think people
are like okay cool like yes that does
get to the uh the end like is this the
best path to getting there like what if
there's a better path to getting there
right how does google maps know
and do you think that consumer behavior
has to change like consumer psychology
uh obviously google search results right
there's some machine learning that's
going on there and kind of learning what
your preferences are what's the best
information out there helping to kind of
surface the best search results if i
think of music recommendations and uh if
i'm using spotify or itunes or something
like that and they go and they tell me
what's the next song that they think
i'll like uh we've talked a little bit
uh about investing and the ability for
uh analysis of a data set and then kick
out kind of a conclusion like
there's plenty of people who are
trusting this stuff today what's holding
back the rest is it just time and the
changing of their consumer psychology so
i think about it a couple ways
you need like for mainstream crypto
adoption you need consumer behavior to
change right they're doing something one
way and now they have to do something a
completely different way right so that's
going to take a long time and it
requires like a major shift in
psychology however for ai or for machine
learning or whatever you want to call it
it's happening in the background it's
progressively getting better and better
every day and it's just happening as we
kind of run through our day-to-day lives
so there's either people that are using
technology or they're not using
technology and if you're using
technology it is going to start to have
an incremental advantage over your life
every single day how important are uh
optimizing for specified outcomes so in
the example that you gave earlier where
you're like oh we thought we could type
something in and eventually we would
just like create an application
obviously it's pretty important if you
want to build something that looks more
like instagram versus maybe an
enterprise software tool right you'd
have to tell the machine i want x and
then it would figure out how to go do
that when it comes to machine learning
do you need to know what insight you're
looking for or is there the ability to
just serve at the data set and say like
hey you just come back to me with
whatever patterns you find i actually
don't know what i'm looking for yet
it's an interesting question um it
depends so i think
the way we think about it is that
problem for example is a very broad
problem so the algorithm wouldn't
necessarily be able to get you like the
perfect app right the algorithm would
not be able to tell you like you know
based on what you're thinking in your
head this is what the app you want look
like this is why it was a really hard
problem to solve but
for specific instances right so for
example i'm trying to like i'm trying to
do stock price performance and i'm
looking at all of the historic price to
earnings on a particular stock right and
i want to understand like given all the
previous historicals of the stock what
do i think is the likely kind of next
outcome it's very precise what do i
think the like forward-looking price to
earnings might be
that is a clear scoped problem that you
can task the algorithm on
but like having something that's very
creative very broad is a very difficult
problem to solve
and when you think about it in the
investing framework uh is it rather than
like hey pick
a stock instead you can say like which
is the one that is likely to go up the
most by the end of the year or pick the
thing that is likely to go down the
least in you know a certain type of
environment like how do you think about
this machine learning artificial
intelligence approach to investing
i think it's less broad even than that
okay like rather like on the stock level
it's more on the specific indicators
right so like sentiment is a great
example of this and we don't necessarily
know if sentiment is a leading or
lagging indicator so like is a stock
with good sentiment going to go up as a
stock with bad sentiment go down but the
way we think about it as part of our
models is you know stocks that have
you know call it high or low sentiment
could just be a good indicator not to
buy so you take an example like a
valiant pharmaceuticals right this
company
took a huge hit because you know fraud
and all kinds of horrible stuff going on
and you know there they still did
meaningful revenues right any kind of
value stock screener would say okay
valiant pharmaceuticals make sense as a
purchase but any investor any
institutional investor that knew the
stock would say i wouldn't touch this
company with a 10-foot pole
so
what this can tell us is like look you
know the fundamentals of the company
might be good but the sentiment of that
company is pretty bad we should just
stay away from that company rather than
using as an indicator to buy or sell the
way we think about it though is that
sentiment is like sentiment is a clearly
scoped problem where you can use
artificial intelligence or machine
learning to understand what is the stock
sentiment right so we can look at tweets
we can look at news articles we can look
at analyst commentary we can aggregate
those various data sets we can scrub
that data with relative ease and then we
can you know create a sentiment score
and when you do that how accurate are
these types of models so let's just
stick on sentiment for example uh if i
gave you two stocks
could you come you know uh pretty close
is it something that like oh we're
always improving but like we still don't
have a ton of confidence in actual
sentiment like measurement
how do you think about accuracy
i would say it's very accurate when you
think about is something high or low
sentiment right so a company that is
getting you know
bashed in the press for example our
model is going to say that is a low
sentiment stock
a company that is getting lots of great
positive commentaries probably going to
be a high sentiment stock the challenge
is what do you do with that data right
how do you know whether or not there's
something that you can trade on that
stock or not there's a lot of people
that have tried they've created hedge
funds around this how do we try trading
on sentiment how do we trade on stock
tweets um but it's a really hard problem
because there's no real answer as to
does sentiment move a stock up or down
so sentiment's a thing where uh if i go
and i read the news i probably can come
to the same conclusion as the computer
right if i'm on twitter if i'm in in
forums or kind of whatever your means of
content ends up being like uh a human
likely will come to the same conclusion
on sentiment are there things where
humans have a really hard time coming to
the same conclusion as the computer that
you guys look at
the challenge when you think about
holistic portfolio construction is
you're looking at so many different
types of assets right so a human is
going to be able to do a similar to just
as good of a job looking at one
particular stock we might be able to
look at way more data points and do it
faster but if you're thinking about
building a holistic portfolio
you need to be looking at tons of data
points for tons of different stocks you
know hundreds of stocks potentially and
a human just you know can't do that
nearly as well as a computer can with
the speed and the precision that a
computer can do it makes uh makes sense
and also the computer doesn't sleep the
computer doesn't get sick right all
these things i think uh kind of older
folks usually joke about the computer
but like they are true to a degree um
and so when you think about uh kind of
the market that you're going after today
how much of the finance world is already
using some of these technologies and
kind of up to speed on what i think you
and i would look at as like no-brainers
in the future like these technologies
will be used versus it's still being
done the same way it was you know 10 20
30 years ago this episode is brought to
you by eight sleep good sleep is a game
changer and the eight sleep pod is the
best sleep machine i sleep on it every
single night a great night of sleep
allows you to be healthier be more
arrested and have more energy throughout
the day and on the brand new eight sleep
pod three you can sleep as cold as 55
degrees fahrenheit or as hot as 110
degrees fahrenheit that's the secret of
thermoregulation better sleep better
energy get yourself innate sleep you can
go to eightsleep.com
today to go ahead and get 150 off your
order aidsleep.com
not only do i sleep on it every night it
literally changed my life and i begged
the founders to let me invest in the
company eightsleep.com
go get yourself an eight-sleep pod and
get a better night of sleep
very far behind okay and everyone knows
it needs to change
but there's a couple problems
first is switching costs so when you
think about some of these large
institutions that have built software
there's so much tech debt that's
continuously stacked up on software that
is like 20 plus years old you know
trading systems portfolio management
systems software that it will cost these
institutions
billions of dollars like
hundreds of millions billions of dollars
to move away from onto something new and
a lot of those institutions just don't
want to you know go through that pain
they don't want to go through that
hassle right it's part of the reason why
ibm is such a big business right because
someone has to maintain all of this
but that's going to slowly start to
erode over time because what's going to
happen is technology right now you know
might not might not you know hold one of
these institutions back but in five
years and seven years and 10 years as
people start to do you know do more
things on their own you know through
technology these institutions are going
to have to start to change but the time
it's going to take them to change the
time it's going to take them to evolve
is going to be too far gone yeah so
taking this is kind of like a viewpoint
that you have today six years after
starting the company take me back to
when you start the company so you meet
your co-founder uh when you're 12 at uh
i'm gonna call it intelligent camp
because uh unfortunately my parents were
not uh forward-thinking enough to send
me to uh to a camp like that uh between
12 and 16 you guys were still working on
things together or just like staying in
touch or what was your relationship
between when you met and then you
actually started the company yeah so
like the specific stories it's pretty
funny so i'm from cleveland ohio my
co-founders from detroit michigan okay
and you know very traditional families
very traditional backgrounds
and when we got back from camp we're
like well we stayed friends we're like
we want to make some money right like
school's easy like we should make some
money so we like that's why we're
different by the way because you said
school was easy
like we should make some money and
the way we think you know we should make
money is by building apps you know it
started as an iphone game we built then
we started building apps for small
businesses so i created a little web
page and posted a press release actually
to get my first couple of apps and small
business owners reached out we had like
the canadian craigslist there's one that
reached out we had like a gas station we
had a couple conferences conferences
like zaps and we were able to start
building apps for all these people we
made
thousands of dollars how much were you
charging we were charging different
prices it was like honestly i wish i had
some kind of pricing formula but we
didn't we just whatever we thought we
could get the person to pay is uh is is
what we would charge them so anywhere
between kind of five thousand dollars an
app all the way up to like twenty thirty
thousand dollars an app that is usually
how most young people start with pricing
is like do i think they'll say yes to a
thousand right like oh they said yes
damn i should ask for 2 000 right you
just kind of work your way up until
somebody starts telling you no and you
know it's funny it's because like you
know the amount of value we were able to
provide for the little cost compared to
like you know some of the bills i see
advise um for specific things i'm like
wow these people got a lot of value out
of us for very little cost yeah but
we started building apps and you know
runic my co-founder is this math prodigy
and she was one of the brightest math
minds in the country
and a professor reaches out from a very
notable institution you know asking hey
you know i run the artificial
intelligence lab here can you kind of
join
your math researcher math research
translates very well every day i
research can you join and can you start
you know helping me solve some of these
problems and he's working on restricted
boltzmann machines and it's type of
artificial intelligence
and we were wondering like you know all
these small businesses want apps it's
2013 2014 they all want apps this is
becoming the hottest thing like every
every business was expected to have an
app like what if we built the software
we call it syscat
that you could type in your app idea and
our system would build you the app
and we spent all of the money we made
on building apps you know bootstrapping
it to build this you know company we're
like we're not gonna be able to raise
any venture financing we're gonna find
some people on the internet and they're
gonna be our first engineers
and we just went on all kinds of
different web forums to try and meet
people we ended up meeting this engineer
who actually unfortunately had to
hacked into sony media as part of the
hacks and and i went to jail so that was
unfortunate but
um a number of different engineers and
they helped us bootstrap the first
initial version of the product but we
were running out of money like we didn't
think we could solve the technical
problem it was just too complicated of a
of a tool to solve at this point in time
my you know grades and score aren't that
great because i'm spending all of my
time building building the startup but
we met this guy who was a former
investment banker and he's like look you
know even though this company might not
be working out
you guys know so much about and machine
learning there are all these consulting
opportunities through these expert
networks and working with these
financial institutions specifically
you can consult on how ai works and
teach you know financial institutions
how ai works so like that sounds great
so we started doing that and we're
charging 700 bucks an hour to charge to
to to meet with financial institutions
and educate them on how artificial
intelligence works and these are like
big bulge bracket banks so you know mass
mutual rbc royal deutsche asset
management big firms and we would get on
the phone with managing directors
analysts whomever and talk through
artificial intelligence talk through the
latest and greatest technologies but
what started to happen
is that we were talking to different
people in these organizations and the
wealth management decisions kept on
coming up
the
sense that we had these massive wealth
management groups
50 of morgan stanley's revenue is 30 of
goldman sachs's revenues like massive
scale to these wealth management orgs
but our wealth managers you know we
believed at the time were great money
managers but in reality they were
relationship managers and it was why
they weren't going away it was why robo
advisors weren't going to replace them
because they had this relationship they
could keep with the client but all these
institutions were trying to understand
how can we leverage ai machine learning
to be able to make our wealth managers
smarter to be able to help them make
better investment decisions make better
portfolio decisions so
we start to think about this problem
and
we do a couple projects with you know
large banks and we realize what if we
just build this on our own what if we
build our own software portfolio
optimization software using machine
learning and we sell it to large
institutions and what were they trying
to get at they were trying to get at uh
getting a better return for their
clients at like task
tax loss harvesting uh something else
what were they optimizing for so at the
time
that what they were optimizing for and
what we were optimizing for was slightly
different okay they were optimizing for
how can we help tell the story to our
wealth managers how can we help you know
how do we have one kind of platform that
can deliver insights on clients
portfolios that can help them recommend
investments all powered by ai um what we
were thinking about is like all of these
institutions have all these portfolio
managers they don't need to have
portfolio managers an algorithm can do
their job just as well and the advisor
themselves can work directly with the
algorithm can work directly with the
platform and you can cut the portfolio
manager out so basically there's a bank
let's call it right you know abc bank uh
that bank has uh the financial advisor
now the advisor in some capacity is
really doing customer relationship right
it's managing the relationship uh people
do not want to talk to a computer they
want to talk to a person uh they're able
to sell but they're also able to do
client retention and those types of
services but a lot of times the
financial advisor is not the one
actually making the investments they're
simply saying okay you know uh client uh
uh joe why don't you take uh 10 of your
assets and put it into our uh public
market you know whatever vertical
focused fund oh take another 10 of your
assets and put it in this other fund or
whatever and then there's portfolio
managers for those funds that are
actually managing the capital exactly
and that's where you guys thought that
you could basically
uh rip those folks out and replace them
with technology exactly sorry if there's
any portfolio managers that listen to
the podcast there's a lot don't worry um
but the idea was like you know there's
all of this you know all of these people
in these institutions that are
delivering relatively generic investment
solutions and we can replace it with one
kind of piece of software that can
deliver highly personalized investment
solutions to each individual client
but at the time we were thinking more at
the fund levels who were trying to think
like okay given a strategy that one of
these places might have they might sell
through the advisors how can we just
automate that strategy
we called that tool fsai financial
services artificial intelligence the two
of us built it ourselves and how long
did it take it took us
six months
and the funny thing was there was a
state stock market challenge going on
and i used the algorithm um to allocate
my portfolio in the state stock market
challenge and i came in second place so
interesting
who was the winner i got a thousand
bucks out of some kid from some other
school and he was just licking his
finger and sticking in the air and
picking stocks must have been i don't i
don't know inside trading yeah right who
knows what he was doing
but uh either way the idea back then was
returns it was performance
but there was a school trip to detroit
startup week and jamie dimon had this
big initiative in detroit and he was
speaking on stage and he gets off stage
we rush him on stage you're like jamie
this is what we're working on fsai do
you think that jp morgan would buy this
and he's like look jp morgan has a lot
of tools i don't think jp morgan's going
to buy this
you know it was a whole it was a whole
discussion and a long long discussion
now for five minutes
but we're like well [ __ ] like you know
if jp morgan's not going to use this and
you know we're young and
they're not going to use this like what
are we what do we do
um
so we ended up meeting this financial
advisor in philadelphia
and he had this 300 million dollar
independent ria practice and he said to
us
advisors are leaving big institutions at
such a rapid rate they're all going
independent advisors are leaving the big
you know bulge bracket institutions and
they are taking their books of business
with them they're starting up their own
practices and they have very little
technology that can help them build and
manage portfolios they don't really have
an operating system around their
investments so they would they would eat
this up they would dig it
so we
were like okay we're going to build the
software for independent advisors we're
almost going to build the shopify like
operating system for independent rias to
help them build and manage portfolios so
every single day after school we would
talk to like five to eight financial
advisors we would post these job ads and
just have lots and lots of advisors
apply to the job ads
and it was our growth hacked way of
meeting advisors and doing customer
research and the way we thought about it
was how do we understand the psychology
of these advisors right most of these
people in the space are just building
investment products they're not actually
trying to enable advisors to sca scale
their business and like make them better
at their jobs
how do we understand the psychology of
the advisor and sell into that
psychology so we spent all of this time
talking to advisors we had hundreds of
conversations with advisors and we
realized there was something there and
one of those people we hired
was a former advisor and he loved the
product he loved the vision that we were
going after he's like okay i'll be your
kind of first employee and i will build
this company with you guys
and he had sold his ria practice he
could afford to work on equity we were
using the money from consulting to kind
of bootstrap the business early days
and we met these two phd machine
learning ai quants and
one worked at morgan stanley the other
one worked ex google and they were the
early team that basically helped us
build where do you meet those people the
first version of eyes angel list
actually sure so some runic actually
worked with in the past others we were
the resources that were available that
just weren't utilized very very well by
startups back in you know 2015 like
angellist and other job sites that now
are probably inundated where there was a
lot of really high quality talent that
wanted to just work on startups with
startup problems that was a great place
to uh to recruit from and was the team
all together when you first started or
was it remote everyone it was actually
we all started remote um i was running
you know it out of my parents or like
house in cleveland and so was my
co-founder in detroit we were in high
school at the time and then the team was
actually all for the most part based on
the west coast in san francisco which is
an interesting part of the story because
what happens is i realize that this is
becoming such a core part of my life and
this is what like you know some people
have a passion others have a calling
like this was my calling like this is
the thing i want to spend the rest of my
life on
and i decided you know what screw school
like i'm gonna drop out and i'm gonna go
move to san francisco so i moved to san
francisco i live in the tenderloin which
was not too fun of an experience but it
was all i can afford at the time and we
had a we work and we couldn't even
afford the wework membership so we just
snuck we had one membership and we snuck
all people in every day and no one
seemed to notice um
and my co-founder at the time was still
in high school and his parents said you
know you have to go to college and you
know at this point like my parents don't
like me because i left school
so your parents were pissed that you
left they were passed okay they ended up
coming around to it but they were upset
and your uh your parents are indian yes
they are indian and are they uh
traditional indian parents who wanted to
be a doctor or a lawyer yes doctor
engineer yeah i didn't know this whole
thing and i've got a couple of friends
who are indian and like the joke is
always like oh uh indian parents
whenever something happens to the news
they like text their kids and like why
can't you be like you know whatever they
see in the news oh my gosh there's so
many people that we were compared to you
know my co-founder is this huge chip on
his shoulder because his cousin is like
this you know brilliant kid who like
went to harvard and got a job at
palantir and his parents are always like
oh you know
you know harsh did this big thing very
well you know live up to that so every
indian kid has this chip on their
shoulder
um
and like i definitely had one i think
like a lot like they're very very
comparative yeah how old were you when
you moved to san francisco i was 16 16.
i just turned 17. and uh did you know
anyone in san francisco other than the
people who were working at the company i
knew that people were working at the
company and i cold emailed and called
linkedin messaged a couple of people to
like meet my first group
of people
and did they think you were crazy oh
everyone thought it was crazy okay but
i'm moving the tenderloin and my
co-founder gets an invite to this
barbecue at this place called the crypto
castle i'm not sure if you've heard of
it yeah jeremy gardner jeremy gardner so
you know jeremy gardner says hey look
i've got this bunk bedroom you can live
here so i lived in the crypto castle
for about two years and i saw the
bitcoin run up which was a pretty cool
thing um and it was a it was kind of my
initial launch pad in san francisco and
i was around a lot of young lots of
people coming in and out of there right
and using a lot of people building
companies uh all of that um when you
actually quit
high school you didn't graduate i didn't
graduate okay but i did some community
college credits okay and i did these
summer college classes so i was able to
get enough credits at the end of the day
to get a diploma like a couple years
later got it and so when you do that
is this like a burn the boats moment
like
if you're leaving there's no like coming
back home big mom and dad you were right
like i should have gone to college and
like i apologize
or is this like no like i got to make
this work because i'm definitely not
going back oh i had no choice like i
think that entrepreneurs when they have
a set of like when there's desperation
right when they have like no other
choice when you have no other
optionality you were forced to make it
work and that's the situation i was in i
was forced to make it work there was no
going back and it was like more like it
was my passion it was the thing i wanted
to spend my life on they're like i had
no alternatives right like there was no
like there was nothing waiting for me on
the other side and i had to do it with
very little money so at 16 you you start
to run the company right uh what are
some of the things that looking back now
like what are some of the mistakes that
you made where you're like i was 16 like
i just didn't know
i mean i would say every mistake is
probably
probably
what ended up happening i mean i would
say i probably have better learnings
given that given the period after we
were funded and after we started have
scale about what i would have done
differently okay but when i was 16 i was
trying to build a company i was doing
whatever i could and i was trying to be
as scrappy as possible so i think the
lesson you know going forward that i
think i did well
was i stuck it out right i had like a
semblance of grit and like i didn't give
up and i think in order to be an
entrepreneur and like you can see in
this market environment you can see it
just broadly speaking if you quit right
because something is hard because
there's not something proven whatever it
might be because it's the easy way out
like you're never going to find like a
meaningful amount of success and i think
that if you continue to work at
something and you continue to iterate
success is going to start to compound
over time it's going to continuously get
easier and you're going to learn more
and that learning is going to continue
to compound over time what was
fundraising like initially
so
what happened with fundraising
was so my co-founder decides to go to
college
and i'm like [ __ ] my co-founder is going
to college what am i going to do so i
decided to move on to his dorm room
floor okay he's this little mattress
topper it's two inches thick okay and we
put it on the floor he's single and like
i just sleep on that and i'm like runic
if
you drop out of school like what it like
what what it needs to be true and he's
like look if we raise a million bucks i
can convince my parents to drop out of
school so i'm like sure like let's go
out and raise some money and originally
we actually tried to raise money and i
had just made cold calls and cold emails
i'd
cold emailed 100 people
and i would just continuously email them
i know it would ever reply so i was like
okay well the only way that i can get
fundraising to work is if we have some
kind of social proof if someone like
introduces us to someone but like at
this point we still don't really know
anyone
so we're at upenn
we start using the u-pen resources there
are some investors there's this guy
named josh koppelman who went to
u-pen who's an incredible vc from
first-run capital and he had introduced
us to these two guys nat turner and zach
weinberg who founded flatiron health
and they said look
we don't know if this whole ria wealth
management technology thing is going to
work but we like you guys we'll give you
your first 100 grand and it came in
perfect timing because the employees
they were working for you know basically
no salary for two years and they were
finally starting to get pressure from
their spouses to like you know take some
cash um why are you working for a 16
year old for no money you know it's
funny because we didn't even tell them
our age at the time yep um
but they asked for cash and you know we
were like about to call it quits we were
like look if this doesn't work by the
end of the year if we aren't able to
raise capital and it's probably february
is the lowest point it had ever been i
was very depressed it's like if we can't
make this work if we can't raise capital
like we'll call it quits like we'll
we'll stop the company
and
we ended up getting that first check it
was the most excited it ever been and i
could i knew i could like finally pay
to you know cover operations and pay for
salaries and
nat and zack helped us raise the next
couple hundred grand and then they
introduced you to like angel investors
investors vcs and
keith for boy and ben ling co-led our
seat around so i think we were keith's
first investment at founders fund first
or second investor okay and then ben
ling with his new fund stayed co-letter
seed rattle we raised 2 million bucks so
then runic dropped out of school
moved back to the bay area we were back
in the crypto castle because we still
didn't pay ourselves any salary we
realized that wasn't sustainable so we
paid ourselves something a little lived
in an apartment and we started scaling
the business we started we got
registered with the sec we were actually
the youngest different people to be
registered with the securities exchange
commission which is very fun for us
and we realized that we needed to be a
money manager we needed to actually
manage the money
with the general premise advise being
we're going to sell the software to
independent rias we're going to help
them build their clients highly
personalized investment portfolios we're
going to automate the management of
those portfolios we're gonna provide the
technology to explain those portfolios
so advisors instead of you know building
portfolios could now be focused on their
client relationships can now be focused
on growing their practice everything
else would be handled by our system and
that was like kind of what we were
working towards at that point in time
we
had seen the show silicon valley and
always like wanted to do this like
startup battlefield thing yeah i thought
it would be interesting and i would
recommend any entrepreneur do this and
the reason why is because there's a lot
of great recruiting benefits to having
that kind of pitch or video on on the
techcrunch website
but
techcrunch was having this
like happy hour
with sequoia okay and we went to this
happy hour we didn't really feel like we
needed sequoia or any kind of investors
we had founders funded at the time we
had some money we're like we don't need
to raise any more capital and we're
sitting at the pretzel station because
we just love free food we didn't want to
pay for food
and chowing down on pretzels and this
guy comes up to us name is sean it's
like
what are you what are you idiots working
on and
[Music]
[Laughter]
it's basically how he tweets so yeah
we love sean sean sean's brilliant um
but
you know he's like what are you guys
working on and we're like oh we're
building the software for financial
advisors to like help them build
portfolios the whole vision is to kind
of automate asset management and it's
like that's really interesting like i
was at this retreat with john and
patrick collison and someone mentioned
that you know
financial advisors are the one part of
the market that for some reason
technology hasn't replaced them and they
continue to grow year after year after
year but no one's built any software for
them
and you know shortly after that sequoia
preempts us on a seed round
and then sean actually helps
individually recruit lots of talent for
us which was helpful
and then we decided we need to move the
company from new york from san francisco
to new york because new york was a
better hub for financial talent because
all the financial dna was actually in
new york wasn't in san francisco sequoia
then preempts us on a series a round in
the pandemic it's and shortly thereafter
ravi at sequoia premium persona series b
round we've now raised like 50 million
bucks and we start to scale assets on
the platform
we're still only managing you know a
couple million bucks in assets across a
handful of financial advisory firms
but it's proving that the product works
and it's working pretty well at this
point in time
and then
we start to build out a small sales team
i'm starting to spend a lot of time on
sales and we scale basically in the
period of six months from zero close
called four or five million dollars in
assets basically nothing too close to
half a billion dollars in assets got it
and why was sequoyah preempting the
rounds
uh
i think they liked us they saw the
market opportunity they saw the sizes of
the market
and they saw that you know
standard vc like if you know they didn't
preempt us someone else would and i
think that was pretty clear because lots
and lots of vcs at the time were kind of
swarming around us and vcs love to
pattern match so i think when they see
young founder big market
like oh this is the next stripe and
we're going to invest i think the
challenge is
history
you know
seems like you know some of these
companies were built much quicker with
much more ease than they actually were
and when you think about tackling a
space like the asset management space
where vice's vision is almost to build
the next black rock right we want to
build one platform that all investors
regardless of age or net worth can get a
personalized portfolio in an automated
way across all asset classes which is a
very challenging thing to do given the
size of the market and how you know
taking over the market is by kind of
legacy incumbents although it is the
direction the market's heading in it's
going to be the direction the market
heads in over a you know 10 20 year
period maybe 30 years it's not going to
be something where you know you see
immediate venture scale success in the
period of you know six to eight months
whereas like you can apply you know some
capital you have a standard kind of sas
operating model and you're able to
continuously start to prove revenue it's
very much a space where you can compound
growth more and more over time so
there's a lot of people who are
investors who will listen to this
conversation they hear you say
personalized portfolio and they're
asking themselves what the hell does
that mean what is a personalized
portfolio compared to a normal portfolio
that's a great question
so if you think about what financial
advisors deliver to clients today they
deliver etfs mutual funds managed
investment strategies very generic
investments they don't take into account
your values your goals your risk
tolerance they're just kind of generic
investment strategies
and there's a lot of drawbacks to this
right they're expensive they don't you
know optimize for your taxes
they aren't very explainable and they're
sometimes like pretty hard to manage so
what vise does
is working with financial advisor we can
take in all these different inputs about
a client how much money they have to
invest their goals their net worth needs
they might have their environmental
preferences like do they want to invest
environmentally friendly companies do
they not um strategies they might want
to take maybe they care about value
investing or growth investing maybe
they've got embedded positions because
they work at a company or they have
stock that they inherited at a low cost
basis and then career risks or risks
they might have right maybe they own
real estate they have angel investments
they work in a you know highly regulated
industry whatever it might be fis can
take all those inputs and one simple
questionnaire 30 seconds later build a
highly personalized portfolio of
individual stocks so stocks that match
up a portfolio that matches up to the
client's individual needs so we will
give them a risk adjusted portfolio over
a certain time horizon that is adjusted
and continuously readjusts to the
client's various goals minus all of
their preferences so let's say the
client works at facebook they won't have
exposure to technology or nearly as much
exposure technology they will have no
exposure to facebook they'll be
de-risked from their facebook holding
because facebook makes such a large
percentage of the s p 500
even if you're just investing in index
funds you're overexposed to facebook or
you know those environmental
restrictions you want companies that are
you know environmentally friendly in
your portfolio you'll take out the
companies that are not environmentally
is there like a core um philosophy that
you all follow at like the highest level
like modern portfolio theory 60 40
stocks and bonds and then you kind of
operate off of that or move off of that
based on the preferences or is it you
start from scratch look at the
preferences and then build a portfolio
and if somebody's preferences lead to 90
fixed income and you know 10 percent uh
reits sure that violates everything in a
60 40 you know portfolio uh philosophy
but like starting from scratch gets you
there and like that's the goal like how
do you think about which direction we do
both okay so we have a philosophy like
kind of grounded and empirical evidence
like a value-based investing strategy
kind of like dimensional fund advisors
that advisors can customize based on
various clients needs
and then we offer all kinds of other
different types of strategies as well
but the idea is the advisor has probably
their own strategies and we want to be
able to operationalize their strategy so
the way our optimizer is built it's very
modular it's very open-ended so given a
number of different kind of restrictions
and inputs client inputs or inputs from
the advisor and strategies that my
advisor might have we can build this
personalized portfolio for them
but let's say something doesn't make
sense let's say they have a goal that's
unrealistic let's say they have a risk
tolerance it's too high given the
client's specific needs
our idea is that we will tell the
advisor and the investor through the
whole process the risk and return
trade-offs and the implications of the
decisions they're making on their
portfolio so the advisor will understand
okay given these set of inputs this is
what my portfolio is expected to return
over this period of time kind of like a
forward-looking monte carlo and then the
back-tested returns um you know fitted
for that particular portfolio given a
set of individual stocks but i think
what's also interesting about vise is
because the customization is basically
endless it can service any different
type of client and you can do it in a
highly efficient way so you think okay
what are the other drawbacks as to using
buys over index funds like what about
tax loss harvesting or something like
that right and the reality is so most
advisors today don't actually do tax
loss harvesting most investors don't do
tax loss harvesting but advise not only
do we do tax harvesting but let's say
you're using a robo advisor or you're
using kind of a generic
model portfolio of etfs your tax cost's
harvesting on the fund level so if the
fund goes down you can tax we'll start
with the incremental you know down but
if you're investing in the individual
stocks you can tax harvest the
individual stocks that go down so if
inside of a portfolio or a fund uh one
stock goes down 20 but the overall
fund's only down two percent most people
are stock uh tax loss harvesting the two
percent not the 20 on that specific
position exactly
so whereas vi vise you can you're
investing in the individual stocks and
this is important because you can
understand what you're investing in you
can understand why you're investing in
it but you can tax harvest the
individual positions who gets screwed if
you guys are successful
i think the traditional mutual fund
companies okay the traditional asset
managers
like i have this general belief and you
can already see it mutual funds are
seeing record outflows and it's going to
continue to compound over time i think
there's always going to be a place for
etfs but i think mutual funds are going
to see record outflows i think the
challenge is the retirement business is
so big and it's built on top of the
mutual fund business
um
which is why it's not happening faster
but
drawing the withdrawals
etfs were the big
initial driver and then step two is what
you can call direct indexing or custom
indexing which is
part of a large part of what vise does
and there's only a handful of companies
that are doing it but i think like four
years ago there were less than three
billion dollars in direct indexing
assets
now there are hundreds of billions and
we're on track for you know trillions of
dollars in assets over the next five
years do you think that
vis or similar types of direct indexing
products will eat etfs and mutual funds
completely or do you think that it's
something where no they may just be
products within the platform so if
somebody comes in and gives you your
preference they may go and buy
individual stocks but like could you
still allocate to an etf or to a mutual
fund for sure for etfs and mutual funds
for you know other assets
so but for core equities i think over
some period of time assuming the
on-ramps are gotten right so the way
people start to initially invest and
making it easy low account minimums
things like that um
it will be very you know very much
direct indexing or custom indexing for
those core assets so financial advisor
goes adopts adopts the technology uh is
this something where they're going to
their clients and they're like huh we've
got you know we've got the black box uh
let's fill out this question here and
then in 30 seconds it's going to tell us
you know exactly what you're going to be
invested in or is this something where
they're still having the same
conversation and kind of relationship
management with their client but then
they're going back to the office and
they're using this tech and what i'm
trying to get at is like how much
awareness does the client have that it's
actually this software product that's
determining what the portfolio is versus
they think that it's still the raa or
something like that today's episode is
brought to you by altoi all right have
you wanted to buy bitcoin or over 200
other cryptocurrencies in your
retirement account well now you can with
alto ira they allow you to buy bitcoin
and cryptocurrencies in a tax advantaged
way there's no account or setup fees and
it's super simple to get started you can
go today to altoira dot com slash pomp
to get started alto ira.com
invest in bitcoin or cryptocurrencies in
your retirement account and get all the
tax advantages while still holding
digital currencies alto ira.com
it's both i mean it's disclosed so the
client has to fill out paperwork but
sometimes advisors kind of take credit
for it they use it as a sales tool
advisors are like i've spent this time
building you this personalized portfolio
of individual stocks that perfectly
matches your needs compared to
i've invested you into
you know this generic model strategy or
set of mutual funds and advisors when
stacked up head to head you know the
strategy of personalized stocks will
just always do better yeah you know
ideally how do you guys make money we
charge an asset our management fee okay
so we charge you pepsi got it and when
you go to the ras what is the biggest
objection that they have
there's probably three or four different
objections one being technology so
advisors haven't adopted technology
historically until relatively recently
so technology adoption in the space has
been slow and it's been really slow
around investment management so as it
starts to kind of increase it's going to
uh it's going to continuously go up
i think that's one key one i think two
which we talked a little bit about
earlier is that some advisors just see
themselves as stock pickers i think it's
10 like 80 to 90 percent of advisors now
outsource some or all of their
investment management so it's becoming a
broad part of what they do so advisors
realize they need to outsource
someone gave one of our advisors a
really good piece of advice that you
know the advisor told me which kind of
resonates is that in this business you
can do one of two things you can either
manage the money we can manage the
people and managing the people is a hell
of a lot easier than managing the money
so most advisors realize that their job
is to be their clients sherpa it's to be
their clients therapist their marriage
counselor their closest advisor their
financial planner um the relationship
manager so to speak between them and
their money
and they're staying away from the money
management so they see themselves as the
manager of managers
and it's vice's job to enable those
advisors not the advisors that are
saying okay i'm a hedge fund manager i'm
going to give you my
10 stocks and we're going to outperform
the market yeah how much impact are the
ra seeing right now through things like
the rise of robin hood and so far to the
world
meme stocks kind of this like day trader
uh mentality that seems to have taken
part in some part of the market like is
that affecting inflows to riaa's from
younger people or are they not seeing
that
this is really interesting and i spent a
lot of time diving deep on this so the
average account size on like a robin
hood is like you know five six thousand
the average account size on a betterment
or wealthfront or traditional
robo-advisors probably in the low 20s
and what starts to happen is it is a
great on-ramp for
investors at the earliest stages to
start investing
and to initially get into the markets
but what people realize is when there's
any meaningful amount of wealth
like anything you know 50 000 plus
they are so far away from understanding
how to manage that even with technology
in the loop but they need to go talk to
an advisor someone recommends them
talking to advisors someone who
recommends them to talk to a human and
that human is a critical part of that
process
so
i would say that those traditional
fintechs do a great job at getting you
know people to invest early early on i
think that like people meme stock
trading is just kind of replacing the
gambling budget i don't think that's
actually like investing i think that's
gambling and i think a lot of those
people know that it's gambling and the
money that people use to gamble is very
different than the money they use to
invest you're not day trading at least
you're really not a smart investor if
you're day trading your uh life savings
in your retirement somebody out there is
for sure doing it but we should not vast
majority of people yeah we should not uh
encourage those people but 100
somebody's how they're doing it but
advisors the thing people always wonder
about advisors is that
advisors for younger clients right like
these older you know baby boomer
advisors
aren't going to be the same types of
advisors that are going to be working
with younger clients and people wonder
like well
my you know like i'm a young client like
why would i want to work with financial
advisor that doesn't understand me that
doesn't understand who i am
and the answer to that is pretty simple
which is
more people that look like you that are
young are becoming financial advisors
and there is a new generation of
financial advisors independent financial
advisors that understand all kinds of
different types of clients so we've got
clients that specialize in musicians
we've got clients that specialize with
tech people we've got clients that
specialize with doctors with lawyers
right like there's even an lgbtq
specific advisory firm that just works
with and understands that client base
so
advisors are starting to change become
you know take different forms than the
traditional kind of golf and country
club you know advisor in their mid 50s
that you know your parents probably use
what about bitcoin cryptocurrencies like
it seems on the internet to be this
really dominant asset class and
everyone's super excited about it or
they really really hate it and you kind
of get the extreme reactions but
two trillion-ish dollars for the entire
industry is like pretty small compared
to equities or any of the other asset
classes so like what are you seeing
there see there's 85 trillion dollars in
assets sitting with financial advisors
and it's growing at this staggering rate
and i think what's interesting is like
anthony you and i live in a bubble right
we live in a bubble in you know the tech
world where it seems like crypto is the
most important thing um or one of the
most important things
and the reality is for most financial
advisors if you're a financial advisor
in iowa or your client a person a
teacher in iowa right you probably have
heard of bitcoin a couple of times you
don't really know what it is or how to
invest in it and if you want to see
mainstream adoption of crypto in
people's long-term investment accounts
you need both institutional adoption on
like retirement accounts and kind of on
a mainstream scale to get to investors
that aren't sophisticated and have it as
a default portfolio allocation or you
need to educate the advisor really well
and advisors are starting to seek out
getting educated and through a platform
like advise or like a tool that services
advisors um having crypto on that
platform it's part of our vision right
we want to have crypto as an asset class
we're probably going to roll it out
relatively soon to having crypto as an
asset class that any investor can invest
in as part of a standard portfolio and
what about like regulators how do they
look at some of these technologies right
the uh it's very clear like how do you
regulate a portfolio manager who's
making decisions they either fulfill
their fiduciary duty or they don't and
there's certain rules that they have to
follow
and for the most part 99.9 of them do
when you start to introduce machines and
algorithms and artificial intelligence
machine learning like do any of the
regulatory uh environment change or do
they look at this differently or the
exact same thing yeah i mean the
regulatory environment has gotten very
difficult for fintechs okay um the sec
is going after fintechs really hard but
more about are these fintechs doing
what's in the best interest of their
client
or are they doing what's in the best
interest of themselves and are they
treating the client the way they should
be kind of treated
the way that they think about these
algorithms it's interesting because
we've gone through some of these
processes with regulators is they want
to understand how they work they want to
understand how does the algorithm work
how does it make decisions in the same
way that an advisor would want to
understand it and the same way the
consumer as we talked about earlier they
don't want to just know like hey just
kicked out this random output sounds
like the regulators want to know as well
well if you gave it this data set it
came to this conclusion why exactly
and are they uh enforcing rules there or
is this more of like uh we're on a
fact-finding mission we want to learn
and understand how this stuff works and
then we'll decide if we need new rules
or not
i think it's fact-finding right now okay
there is going because it's still very
new right and the sec is still most of
the regulatory agencies are still you
know they're very smart
which is i think contrary to what a lot
of people believe um is that these
regulators are very very smart but
they're very slow right it takes them a
long time to enact new roles and
understand real problems and i think
that
we're still in kind of fact-finding data
gathering until we can you know create
new policy around some of these software
however regulators are taking note they
are starting to act in a meaningful way
you can see it in a very public way
against companies that are you know
fintech that are not doing what's in
that's clearly not doing what's in their
clients best interest and they're being
deceptive or or otherwise and there's
almost like a zero tolerance policy for
it by the sec which i think has been
pretty interesting yeah um you're a
young person who's now run a company for
six years uh or this company for six
years you haven't had a company before
um and what i find fascinating is i
think that you've learned a lot you've
changed your mind about a lot of ways of
actually operating the business itself
so i thought that what we could do uh is
i'll throw out a couple of topics about
just running a business and you mind
dump on me in terms of uh how you do it
and things that you've learned over the
last six years uh the first one which i
know you have changed your mind on is
okrs uh what is your current thought
process and why did you change your mind
into okrs all right
so i thought okrs were the most
brilliant thing when someone introduced
him to me i think was a
ex-google executive
really big
google executive who's
friends with us and i thought they were
brilliant our whole exec team was like
hey we should do okrs we'll do it on a
quarterly cycle
we'll have our main objective we'll have
all of our different key results and our
feeding inputs and then we'll have this
big deck i created this big deck
presentation that outlines each okr and
each input and the owner of the input
and here's the problem
maybe for a big company they work for
startups they're terrible because
there's usually one thing in the startup
that is holding you back there's one
limiting regent problem over all of the
rest but the entire company needs to be
focused on one metric one objective one
issue and the problem with okrs is
you're distracting yourself
from the key focus if you've got five
different objectives or three different
objectives and
like eight different key results or nine
different key results like you are
looking at so much stuff and to keep a
small team focused on a broad set of
priorities and objectives you're
naturally going to create yourself into
a situation where you kind of like
half-ass each of them you kind of make
some progress on each of them maybe you
make like a lot of progress on one of
them but it's not the right one whereas
to work in us to be successful in a
startup you need to have one thing that
is holding you back between now and
hyperscale
that maybe it's one objective so in our
case it was like assets under management
at the time and one kind of leading
input into that assets under management
which is like onboarded aum from net new
customers
that everyone focuses on the whole
organization obsesses over the whole
organization spends all of their time
and energy thinking about that
everything else you can just let run and
let it operate but if you're thinking
about oh here's how i kind of slightly
improve this and slightly improve that
and slowly improve this you're not
really going to be able to make step
function order change in a
like
major way across all of them and you
need to see success in one in a
meaningful way
let's walk through that decision so uh
when you decide what the one thing is
how did you guys go through that process
to understand it was the aum i mean
what is the difference between more
customer adoption and less customer
adoption like what is usually everyone
knows right like it's something that's
so obvious it's so obvious right like if
you're having a problem with retention
right you have all these customers that
are joining your
new app
and
you know the initial growth is
incredible but retention is staying
really low the whole organization is
going to know that like retention is bad
when you ask everyone in the company
what is the biggest problem you think
the company has everyone's going to have
an answer and hopefully like 50 to 70
percent if not more are gonna have the
same answer that is usually your answer
of what is the key objective
and then how do you communicate that to
the whole team so like once you and the
executive team decide this is the thing
all hands meeting is it like an email a
slack message how do you actually
communicate it see this is the mind of a
ceo that you know it
to you it might be the most important
thing to everyone else it might also not
also be the most important thing so when
you communicate this is the other
problem with okrs because there's so
many of them when you communicate
one of them on all hands or send an
email about it like
it might be important that day people
might not show up people might not but
remember like if you've got one key
objective if you've got one key focus of
your business one metric that you're
tracking it needs to be plastered
freaking everywhere right you need to
talk about this in every conversation
you need to be asking every single
person every single second of the day
what is going on with this one
particular thing and then when you nail
that you can focus on everything else
but until you nail the main thing until
you nail the main focus of the business
nothing else matters and i think the
challenge is as founders we all think
okay there's so much stuff on our mind
there's so many balls we're trying to
juggle and
like we're gonna talk about it once in
all hands we're gonna send a one company
wide email and everyone's gonna get it
and that's just not how people work you
need to talk about it everywhere and one
of our companies uh every single meeting
starts off with a reminder of how many
days since the company was started and
then what the mission of the business is
yeah just over and over and over again
uh to the point where sometimes we call
on people and say hey what what is this
and if somebody doesn't know i don't
care if you're brand new or if uh you've
been around for a while you better know
the answer to that question i agree and
i think that your point about the
repetition ends up being very very
important until it's literally ingrained
in people's heads it's all repetition
and it's got to be simple right it's
going to be a very simple thing that
everyone can think of so we had a new
product
like initiative that we wanted everyone
focused on the whole company and to be
focused on it but we did a very simple
name for it when everyone thought about
that product initiative are we working
on pce too and everyone focused on
working on too it was a simple easy
thing when you have these long drawn out
objectives it's really hard to kind of
keep that in your mind but it's a simple
acronym or simple target
that everyone can think about then
everyone's gonna everyone's gonna
resonate to it how do you do recruiting
today like what are some of the things
you've learned over the last six years
and how to be good at recruiting high
quality talent so i was really good at
this early on i made a lot of mistakes
later on okay there's a couple
interesting things so the first is
having a sequoia
love sequoia but having a sequoia is a
blessing and a curse and the reason why
it's a curse
is because
having such a high quality venture fund
helps you and like big backers and all
this funding and all this press and all
this excitement helps you recruit people
that are actually the wrong people to
recruit at your organization because
they are there because you're a rocket
ship that they think they're going to
make lots of money on but the reality is
you need people that are obsessed with
your mission that are willing to work
their asses off and they're only there
because they love what they're building
they're willing to take a pay cut
they're willing to work extra hard
harder than they would have before and
they're willing to just take [ __ ] that
they wouldn't have taken before and i
think the
like pattern like if people look at you
know
the success and the draw that you have
behind your company like they're going
to join for that reason whereas i think
early on when we didn't really have all
the backing we only had people that
joined because they loved the mission
and they wanted to join an early stage
startup and they wanted to work really
hard and they were willing to take a cut
and they were willing to be extra loyal
versus what happens
after a certain scale is you start to
get people that are there because you
are this big flashy company and you need
to avoid that like the plague like i
used to think like part of the reason
why we were able to raise so much
capital we wanted to raise so much
capital you know high valuations and you
know with big investors is because we
thought it was going to be a magnet for
talent and it is a magnet for talent
it's just oftentimes it's the magnet for
the wrong talent did you run into
problems with raising a lot of money or
with high valuations
it
depends okay so there are problems in
the sense that there's this general
expectation of high valuations and last
year i think everyone had a high
valuation you needed a high valuation
because what would happen is engineers
would come and they'd say hey this
company i'm interviewing at has a high
valuation why don't you have a high
valuation too which is actually the
opposite of what they should be asking
right because there it means that
there's less
right because the way that these
companies say is like we're giving you
two million dollars of equity yes and we
might be giving them you know
300k of equity but it's at a way lower
valuation that could be you know ten
million dollars of equity in the near
future whereas that three million
dollars of equity at that other company
you know could be
a million million dollars of equity
right um
so but that's how people are trying to
think and that's where they were trained
to think and they assigned value of the
company as a proxy for quality and
likelihood of success exactly
and
we like you have high expectations like
you have to grow really fast and
i think the reality is like
it was a good learning lesson for us but
the reality is like this is a business
that is going to take a long time to
build and you do need a lot of capital
so it was a good idea to raise a lot of
capital do you need a lot of people i'm
not sure i don't believe so i think that
the narrative in silicon valley was
always like you have to hire a lot of
people you have to hire executives you
have to scale your team in a really big
meaningful way and you're going to get
more progress and you're going to grow
faster as a result of it i don't
actually think that's true i think if
you are crafty you build a really great
product you have a team that is
incredibly loyal and mission driven even
though they might be a much smaller team
but they're you know obsessed with what
you're building and they're in it with
you every single day in the trenches
then you're probably gonna have a higher
likelihood outcome of success than the
company that has 150 employees big
executives you know a lot of pedigree
that
you know
yeah probably moving a lot slower
they're probably moving like a big tech
company not like a nibble startup yeah
um when you think about working with the
board of directors what are some things
you've learned there
a lot okay um
the challenge with boards generally even
speaking outside of eyes is you've got
lots of different perspectives so
everyone has lots of different
perspectives and they're operating with
very little information so they're only
operating with the information from what
you've told them or for what they've
seen historically in financials or from
you know other you know
metrics or memos you've given them
i think
the challenge is they're giving you
advice
based on what little information they
have and they typically expect you to
take that advice and sometimes you need
to know when to listen to them and when
not to listen to them and it's a hard
line to to draw right you don't know
when the board might be right and you
know their experience might be great you
don't know when you know you actually
are right on this particular decision
and you know you should
you should take that decision the way
that you want to have it solved and i
think that the other issue is that
incentives
are very misaligned right for early
stage businesses where it's like you
have a financial investor and the
financial investor has their lp's they
have their partners they have their
reputation investors care a lot about
their reputation and you know quite
frankly that doesn't really matter for
your business what matters for your
business is you know what is right for
your business what is right for the
growth of your business what is right
for the customers your employees and you
know you're oftentimes the best person
to make that decision not a board member
and i think it gets to this even broader
point which is
a problem that not a lot of founders
talk about but it's actually a really
big problem is advice overload there are
too many people giving you advice
too much of the time there's this
founder that you know there's this these
are your employees there's your
customers there's your board members
there's other investors and you don't
know which direction to go and i think
that it's important just to kind of
listen to yourself and know you know
take advice from a small amount of
people that are consistent in their
advice and that can deliver one way or
another how have you balanced doing work
yourself first delegating are you good
at that or not go to that
i'm not great at this okay and the
reason why i'm not great at this
is because when you start to scale an
organization you're kind of playing this
game of telephone so you'll give work to
a leader and then that work will give
their
will give that work to
their team
and they'll give you some version of
what you want back but oftentimes it is
very far
from what you actually wanted originally
and i think that
the larger the organization gets the
harder it is to communicate the more
you're playing that kind of game of
telephone and i think when you think
about remote work it becomes a
catastrophe like i just don't believe
that early stage startups can be done in
a remote way
maybe if you've been working with the
team for a long time and like you have a
lot of embedded trust and you spend a
lot of time with them in person somehow
it can get done but i don't believe
remote remote companies work
because of this communication miss
overlap
and when you
see that you're not good at something
right or you think hey i could get
better at this like what are the steps
you go through to improve on something
like that are there specific things like
do you go seek out an advisor do you go
and try to find someone who is good at
it that's like another founder like what
have you done to try to get better at
something like delegation or whatever so
historically
i will call the person i think is best
and the nice thing is we've had lots of
resources the best founders the best
executives the best investors that we
can call and understand how do you
delegate
the challenge and why i'm not good at
this is everyone has a different
perspective everyone has different
advice
and
you don't know what advice is always
right for you you don't know the right
direction you can take some people's
advice on some things other people's
advice and other things and
they're not always gonna fit in sync
with each other when when those two
things are related
so
that's why i think i'm not that great of
it because like i don't always know what
direction
like what consistent path to take from
an advice standpoint
talk to me about the touch points with
your executive team right so as you're
running the business uh do you meet with
them
once a day once a week once a month like
like what does that kind of cadence look
like and i think this is more uh style
right as each business leader thinks
about it differently some people want to
hey i want to talk to you every single
day other people say look we've got one
big meeting on wednesday for three hours
all the executives come together and we
kind of review the business how do you
work so we've gone through multiple
different iterations of this like we've
had executives we've lost executives
we've
worked without executives
i don't actually believe that again like
early stage companies like slightly
post-product market fit work with like
seasoned executive teams if you're
pulling seasoned leaders out of you know
big companies and expecting them to work
well in startups you know it's a lost
cause it's not gonna work um
and the structure that those people
typically type to like to type
try and work in um don't work too well
for startups what we did was we did
weekly leadership meetings on wednesday
it was two hours we would have everyone
put together a memo the night before
we'd have a general memo you know and
what happens is everyone gives their
opinion on every different thing and
it's not clear is this the
decision-making meeting are there how
many different decision makers are there
everyone wants to feel like their input
is heard on a particular decision
everyone wants to feel like an owner of
the decision and you as the founder the
person that's running the meeting is
like going crazy because everyone wants
to have their input on the thing and
certain people have different levels of
impact on a particular decision but if
they're all in the meeting their voices
are all relatively equal right so if
you're thinking about a product decision
and your chief people officer is
weighing in a ton on the product
decision and she's the loudest voice in
the room and your head of product isn't
really talking too much right which is
something that commonly happens in a
leadership meeting you know you're
diluting that meeting right so you kind
of need to either tell people like hey
like you know stop talking and like you
know this person's like how do you
handle it you literally just right in
the middle of the meeting say hey you
know be quiet
so
yeah i started to do that in the
beginning i was very polite um
what i actually think works in the right
structure doing this
is
leadership teams don't work as big teams
like you have your team of you have your
group of functional leaders
so this could be five to seven people
and then you have your s team and your s
team maybe it's your like cto maybe it's
your finance leader maybe it's your
co-founder it can't be any more than
like three or four people it's gonna be
a small group and you have to have a lot
of like respect and trust in that group
and you were talking to this team every
single day like they are helping you run
the whole business and they are filled
in they are keyed in on everything
this team will help you make the
decisions this team is the
decision-making body then you have the
information body and the information
body is all the different functional
executive leaders
they might run the people function they
might run the legal function whatever it
might be
and they will help
you keep them informed you do your
two-hour weekly leadership meeting and
you will keep them informed as to what
is going on you will get their
perspective but the decisions are not
made in that meeting the decisions are
not made in that meeting
and do you make the decisions before
the meeting
that it's kind of you're making them all
the time okay but you're clearly logging
those decisions you're logging who's the
dri who's responsible for this
particular decision you have to be very
clear you have a leadership operating
system so in our case we had a
leadership operating system this is how
we make decisions this is who how we
appoint dris this is what a dri is
responsible for it's a dra a directly
responsible individual
we have aors which was really helpful so
aor's are areas of responsibility we
basically had a big spreadsheet in early
stage companies people don't know who's
responsible for what you literally write
out to the specific thing what is the
area of responsibility who is the owner
of the aor
what are they specifically responsible
for what is the backup
so who will in the case they're not
there who's the person you go to and
then what is the process write up how do
you go through this actual process so
the way it works is when someone quits
when someone leaves when someone's out
it's really easy for people to swap in
and take over transition aors
and when you do all of this how much are
you having to train employees on it when
they first show up so a brand new
employee and you're saying hey here's
how we run meetings here's how we do
information sessions here's who the
leadership team is let's actually make
the decision and solve that versus it's
more of uh hey you are an engineer you
are a marketing person you are on the
customer service team
here's what you're going to need to know
on a day-to-day basis and then they'll
kind of over time uh through osmosis
essentially just pick up
okay this is kind of how the
organization works so we did the latter
but moving forward
i think having a formal like week-long
training program even if it only works
one percent of the time that one percent
will continue to compound um and
hopefully it works much more than that
um to how here's how the company
operates here's our culture here's how
we view our values um
here's how we make decisions all of
those different things
and deeply embedding it like almost
having an onboarding class and making
sure people get it right
is really critical and the other part to
culture is like how do you hold people
accountable when they don't do things
like that how do you do it
we're still figuring out the specific
the right way to doing it but it's
usually rewarding people when they do so
we have channel we have slack channels
where we call people out for positively
doing it and then i always give people
feedback like hey i would have liked you
to see this differently in a one-on-one
setting like never criticize people in
public
and how often do you have those feedback
sessions or those one-on-ones are you
doing that uh multiple times a day all
week long with various people in the
company are you doing it just with the
leadership team so previously we did
adjust with the leadership team and we
did two things
um as far as feedback so we did feedback
at the end of every meeting so people
would write down their feedback they
would say okay here's how we thought the
meeting went we'd like carve out 10 to
15 minutes at the end of the meeting
here's how the meeting went here's some
of the learnings here's what i would do
differently next time and everyone would
write it down and we would review it as
a team and then we would put a next
action of like next week we're going to
do this better and then we'd always make
sure to remember that as a team after
every meeting the second thing we did
was on one-on-ones i would do
basically check-ins so i would ask
people i could ask people for specific
like questions about how they would rate
like working with us so how do you feel
our working relationship is this week is
it a two is it a five is it an eight is
it a ten if it's less than eight what
would make it an eight or higher and you
would score it and you would do this
like once a month or once every two
weeks and you would see the scores
progressively change and get better over
time
and
when you saw the score
low
is that your problem or their problem
i mean
sometimes both you have to understand
like what is the component part like why
um
sometimes it is your problem sometimes
it is their problem and then you work
out a plan like what is the next action
what are we going to do differently
the last question i have for you is uh
after running the business for six years
if you go back and uh there's plenty of
young founders who are starting
companies today
what's like the one or two things that
you wish that you knew and you would
really hammer home
so there's a lot of distractions
that is really important to avoid and i
think there's more distractions now than
there was in
20
2015 like whenever i was starting and i
think avoiding those distractions is
really important there's only one thing
that really matters
and like it's your customers and your
product as a result so maybe two things
um
other than that like product and
customers
and like maybe like you can kind of
start to think about like okay so once
you nail product and customers and
you've got culture and you know some of
these other things to running a company
um
nothing none of that other stuff matters
right founders get too obsessed
especially young founders with status
right i fell into this trap i personally
like it just seemed like what everyone
else was talking about and it seemed
like the important thing if you can't
nail customers in product you're going
to fail at everything else
like
the types of vcs you raise money from
the pedigree of the employees you
recruit the
time that you spend on going to founder
networking events all of it it's a waste
of time that i 100 agree it doesn't feel
like that in the beginning right but
over time i think that you realize that
i'm sure you had a ton of impact on
making this together but like
yeah and i'm a huge fan of keith or boy
but um like the miami tech week thing
like half of our employees were like oh
like we want to go to this miami tech
week thing and i'm like look like
the vcs that are like retired and like
want to hang out and
like they can go to miami tech week he's
gonna kill you for saying retired
they can maybe not keith but because
keith has a broader mission which is
trying to get people to miami but
keith aside like
you need to stay focused on the core
objective which is our customers and our
product and anything else that isn't
that miami tech week is a distraction if
you're going for vacation go on vacation
but like all of this other stuff if it's
not vacation it is a distraction
i think look it's just singular focus on
what you feel is the most important
thing right i think it's a pretty fair
uh uh way to look at a business and i
actually think it's a very good way to
look at a business and for those that uh
end up um
uh not liking that like they can work a
different business yeah exactly right
where can we send people to find you on
the internet or find out more about vice
advise.com
and
vi vise.com and i guess i'm on twitter i
haven't been tweeting much but maybe
i'll start again well if i can find the
kanye tweet that means you definitely
gotta start tweeting more exactly
awesome well listen i really appreciate
this i think people will learn a ton not
only about artificial intelligence
machine learning but also what you guys
are building and then how you actually
run the business uh and we'll definitely
have to do it again in the future cool
thank you so much for having me on